Transcriptor: Anna Sobota
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Bueno, he puesto los frenos
porque esto va cuesta abajo
y saldríamos en Vídeos
de Primera, y mejor que no.
¿Sabéis una cosa?
A mí, nunca me ha gustado quejarme.
No me ha gustado nunca.
Pero me quejo como todo el mundo.
A veces es necesario y, otras,
es conveniente
quejarse de las cosas para avanzar
o para mejorar situaciones.
Nos tenemos que quejar
cuando vemos una injusticia grave,
una de estas que clama al cielo.
Nos tenemos que quejar
cuando pisotean nuestros derechos.
Pero cuando yo me tengo que
quejar de una cosa,
¿sabéis lo que hago?
Yo voy, me quejo,
y a otra cosa, mariposa.
No me quedo en la queja.
Yo no le dedico a la queja
ni un segundo más del que
sea estrictamente necesario.
Como digo yo:
en el microcosmos de la queja,
yo, ahí no me construyo un chalet
y me que quedo a vivir en él.
No me quedo instalado.
No me quedo anclado.
Yo voy, me quejo de lo que me tenga
que quejar, y a otra cosa.
Porque creo que esto a mí me ayuda.
Imaginaos que trazamos
una línea imaginaria y
en un extremo ponemos la felicidad,
y, en el otro, ponemos la amargura.
Tenemos que colocar en ella
a estas personas que todos conocemos,
que se están quejando
todo el día por todo,
que parece que se levantan por la mañana
y están escarbando en la tierra para
encontrar algo que no les guste
o buscando errores de otras personas,
quejándose de que las soluciones
que se han dado son distintas
de las que hubieran dado ellas mismas.
Ahora, si estas personas,
que todos conocemos,
las tenemos que colocar
en esta línea imaginaria,
¿dónde las pondríais?
¿Cerca de la felicidad
o cerca de la amargura?
Yo creo que las colocaría más
bien cerca de la amargura
porque uno no puede ser feliz
buscando las cosas que no le gustan.
Empeñándose en encontrarlas.
Por supuesto, no niego que ellas existan,
pero tenemos tantas otras cosas
que sí que nos gustan
y que podemos dar gracias por ellas,
que prefiero buscar éstas.
Porque creo que me hacen más feliz.
Me acercan más al punto de felicidad
que yo quiero.
Por esto, os lo digo que cuando
me tengo que quejar, y lo hago,
pierdo muy poco tiempo en ello.
Porque prefiero dedicar mi tiempo a buscar
esas pequeñas cosas que me rodean,
que están alrededor de mi vida.
Cosas a las que muchas veces
no les damos ninguna importancia.
Ni nos damos cuenta de que las tenemos.
Las minusvaloramos incluso
de manera injusta.
Muchas veces las despreciamos.
Pero son cosas que lo único que hacen es
llenar el depósito de nuestra felicidad.
Y yo prefiero buscar estas cosas.
Claro que tengo motivos para quejarme,
como todo el mundo.
¿Pero sabéis qué pasa?
Imaginaos que esta noche os digo:
mirad, ¿sabéis que?
Voy a hacer una lista de las cosas
que no me gustan,
de las que podría quejarme.
Y, esta noche, cuando me meta en la cama,
voy a repasarla.
¡Venga! ¡Una a una, las cosas que
no me gustan o de las que quiero quejarme.
Pero antes voy a hacer
otra cosa.
Voy a hacer otra lista de las cosas
por las que tengo que
darme con un canto en los dientes.
Las cosas por las que solo
puedo dar gracias,
las cosas que me hacen sentir
un privilegiado en la vida.
Voy a hacer esa otra lista.
Y, antes de empezar con la lista de las
cosas de las que me puedo quejar,
voy a empezar por la otra.
Voy a empezar por lista de las cosas
que tengo que agradecer.
¿Sabéis qué pasará?
Que no empezaré la lista de las quejas.
Me dormiré antes.
También es verdad que
me quedo dormido fácilmente.
Me dormiré antes de terminar con
la lista de las cosas
que tengo que agradecer y
que me hacen sentir feliz en la vida.
No me la acabaré.
No llegaré nunca a la lista de las quejas.
Por esto os digo:
a la queja, el tiempo justo.
Un poco como la Fórmula 1, Stop and Go:
te paras, cumples la sanción
y a otra cosa mariposa.
¡A disfrutar de la vida!
E insisto, motivos tenemos.
Todas las personas aquí tienen problemas.
Y ahora os pido lo siguiente:
que levante la mano
quién no haya tenido nunca
un problema en su vida.
No la levanta ni el Tato.
No la levanta nadie.
A continuación os pregunto:
¿Y ahora qué? ¿Sabéis qué?
Que levante la mano
el que crea que, de aquí en adelante,
no va a tener un problema nunca.
Nadie levanta la mano.
Y sabéis, ¿por qué?
Porque es normal tener problemas.
No hay nadie que no tenga problemas.
El problema va unido a la persona.
Es absolutamente normal
tener problemas
y esto es muy importante interiorizarlo.
Tenerlo claro.
Porque esto nos ayudará a estar preparados
para que cuando llegue un problema;
que llegará,
que cuando nos venga un problema;
que vendrá,
pues ya tendremos algo ganado.
Sabremos que es normal.
No le tenemos que tener miedo
a ese problema.
Y no le debemos tener miedo
a ese problema por una razón muy sencilla:
Porque sabremos cuál será el resultado.
Salvo que el problema se
te lleve por delante.
Salvo ese ejemplo dónde
evidentemente gana el problema.
En los demás casos,
ganamos nosotros.
Los problemas, los que hayamos tenido
a lo largo de la vida, desaparecen.
Se van, nos abandonan.
O los vences.
Pero si no los vences,
te acomodas a ellos.
Pasa lo que sea.
Pero te abandonan.
Los dejas.
Ganamos nosotros.
Y saber esto, junto con entender
que es normal tener problemas, te ayuda.
Cuando yo tenga un problema,
e insisto, que lo tendré.
Cuando venga, sabré:
Vale. Aquí estás. Te doy la manita
y vamos a caminar juntos un tiempo
hasta que te canses
o hasta que te deje en la cuneta.
Porque voy a ganar yo.
Y voy a ganar yo
porque siempre he ganado.
Y ahora no hay motivo
para que sea diferente.
Esto es una cosa
que nos ayuda muchísimo.
Pero tenemos que
tenerlo interiorizado.
Tiene que ser
una decisión apriorística.
Soy consciente de que
voy a tener problemas,
pero también sé
que los voy a vencer.
¡Qué voy a ganar yo!
Seguramente, el problema más serio
que he tenido en mi vida
fue cuando tuve un accidente de coche
con 20 años y me quedé parapléjico.
En ese momento se abre
un escenario nuevo en mi vida.
Se abre un periodo de incertidumbre.
Yo no sabía si me iba a recuperar o no.
Si me iba a recuperar en 1 semana,
en 1 mes, en 5 meses, en 1 año, en 5 años,
o si no me iba a recuperar.
No tenía ni idea de que lo pasaría.
Pero en ese proceso, en ese tiempo,
las cosas que yo no podía hacer,
las cosas que había tenido,
las que podría haber tenido,
las que podrían haber pasado...
Todas estas cosas me dejaron
de interesar.
A mí lo único que me interesaba
era lo que yo podía hacer.
Lo que estaba al alcance de mi mano.
¿Qué tenía que hacer entonces?
Primero, tenía que recuperarme
de las lesiones físicas que tenía.
Luego, tenía que ponerme fuerte
para aprender a pasar por unas paralelas,
andar incluso con unas muletas,
aprender a ir a una silla de ruedas.
Yo no había llevado
una silla de ruedas en mi vida.
Aprender a pasarme a la bañera,
a montarme al coche.
Aprender a vivir de otra forma,
de momento.
Luego, ya veremos.
No sabía lo que iba a pasar,
pero de momento tenía que hacer eso.
Pues adelante, ¡a por ello!
Eso es lo que yo podía hacer.
Y en eso me centraba.
Todo lo demás era
tirar piedras sobre mi tejado.
No iba conmigo.
No lo hice en ningún momento.
Y podéis decir:
bueno, esto es una actitud positiva.
Sí, lo es.
Es actitud positiva.
Estamos en una época en la que
nos están llenando con unos mensajes que
nos dicen que tenemos que vivir
con alegría, con ilusión, con entusiasmo.
Que tenemos que ir contentos
por la vida que tenemos.
Estoy de acuerdo
pero frena un poco, ¿eh?
Frena un poco porque vete con este mensaje
a alguien, por ejemplo, que ha perdido
su casa ahora en la isla de La Palma.
Vete a decirle que hay
que vivir con alegría
o que tenemos que ir
contentos por la calle.
¿Sabéis a que nos invitan?
Parece que tengamos que ir por la calle
dando saltos de alegría,
sonriendo, abrazándonos
los unos a los otros.
Y esto no es real.
Esto no es así.
La gente va andando por la calle,
unos sonríen más, otros sonríen menos.
Las personas tienen problemas.
Es normal tener problemas.
Es normal afrontarlos.
Y puedes sonreír, sí.
Pero la actitud positiva no es eso.
La actitud positiva, para mí,
es apretar los dientes.
Cuando tienes
un problema o una adversidad:
apretar los dientes
y seguir adelante.
Eso es actitud positiva.
No es nada más que eso.
Si lo puedes hacer contento, perfecto.
Se puedes hacer sonriendo, perfecto.
Pero la esencia es apretar los dientes.
Muchas veces la actitud positiva,
¿sabéis lo que es?
Es no caer en la contraria.
No caer, no incurrir en la actitud
negativa, no hundirte.
Luchar cuando hay fuerzas que te
empujan hacia el abismo de la depresión
y vencerlas, aunque no lo hagas sonriendo.
Vencer esas fuerzas,
eso es la actitud positiva.
Esa es la actitud
que a mí y a todos nos gusta.
Luego, si lo haces sonriendo o no,
carece de tanta importancia.
Haciéndolo sonriendo se considera
una manifestación más.
Pero hay también muchas otras formas
de manifestar la actitud positiva.
Hay tantas como queramos
pensar y encontrar.
Algunas son muy sencillas.
Os voy a contar una sencilla
manifestación de la actitud positiva:
Es ser agradable.
Fijaos que fácil: ser agradable.
Porque para ser agradable no tienes
que ir a la universidad.
No tienes que ir a un curso de formación.
No tienes que ir a un centro.
No tienes que hacer un Máster.
Todos sabemos lo que tenemos que
hacer para ser agradables.
No nos cuesta nada.
Todos lo sabemos. Es muy fácil.
Yo si quiero ser agradable, soy agradable.
El hecho de ser agradable,
aparte que te ayuda a ti,
hace que transmitas buenas
sensaciones a la gente que te rodea.
¡Ojo! Qué llego a conclusiones peligrosas
o que te hacen pensar...
Si yo pienso: oye, ser agradable,
a mí no me cuesta nada.
Nadie me tiene que enseñar
a ser agradable.
Es gratis ser agradable.
Esto me lleva al siguiente punto:
Si yo no soy agradable,
es porque no me da la gana.
Sé lo que hago.
No me da la gana ser agradable
aunque no me cuesta nada.
Aunque es gratis.
¿Por qué no soy agradable?
O, ¿por qué no somos más agradables?
Esto me hace reflexionar.
Entonces, desde mi punto de vista,
ser agradable no es solo una virtud.
Es algo mucho más.
Para mí ser agradable es una virtud
y, además, un deber.
Yo me autoimpongo el deber de
ser agradable o de intentarlo.
Lo conseguiré o no pero, por lo menos,
intento ser agradable con todo el mundo.
No solo con mi familia, amigos
o compañeros de trabajo
sino con todo el mundo.
Con cualquier persona que
se cruce en mi camino.
A lo mejor le cruzo una mirada, le cruzo
una sonrisa o le cruzo dos palabras.
Me preguntan: ¿dónde está tal calle?
Con esa persona también
intento ser agradable.
¿Por qué? Porque no me cuesta nada.
Y no digo que, en ese momento en el
que esa persona interactúa conmigo,
le proporcione felicidad
o le transmita alegría. No.
Pero quiero que se lleve
una buena sensación.
Aunque no volveré a verla
nunca más en mi vida.
Pero, ¿qué me cuesta?
No me cuesta nada.
Y esto es una manifestación,
como otras mil,
de tener una buena actitud.
Una actitud positiva en la vida.
Sé que con esto
no cambiaremos la sociedad.
Muchas veces nos preguntamos,
¿cómo podemos cambiar la sociedad?
¿Cómo podemos mejorarla?
Pues, no tengo ni idea.
Esto se me escapa de las manos.
Seguramente se os escapará
de las vuestras también, ¿no?
Y aquí dicen que hay que pensar
de forma global, a lo grande.
Yo creo que no, que tenemos
que hacer todo lo contrario.
Tenemos que pensar en pequeñito.
Porque lo que está en nuestras manos,
seguramente no es cambiar la sociedad.
Nosotros lo que podemos hacer
es ocuparnos de nuestra propia parcela.
De barrerla cada mañana
y tenerla bien limpia.
Puedo ser agradable con todas
las personas que entren en mi parcela.
Ya sea mi familia, sean mis amigos o no.
Estén mucho o poco tiempo.
Compartan mucho o poco conmigo.
Compartan solo un instante.
Sea el cartero que me trae
una carta a casa
o cualquier otra persona que
se acerque a mi parcela.
Porque, a lo mejor, de este modo, consigo
que, a su vez, sean agradables conmigo.
Es difícil ser borde con alguien
que es agradable contigo.
Entonces, a lo mejor animas
a estas personas.
Y vete tú a saber...
Igual las animas también para
que, a su vez, digan:
Oye, pues mira, yo también voy a barrer mi
parcela con la misma escoba que éste.
Voy a intentar ser
un poquito más agradable.
Y, a su vez, lo mismo piensa la persona
de la parcela de al lado.
Y, parcela a parcela,
el terreno se va haciendo más grande.
¿Cambiaremos el mundo?
¿Cambiaremos la sociedad?
No, seguramente, no.
Pero habremos hecho algo bien.
Y ,desde luego, no habremos
causado ningún daño.
No habremos generado
ningún tipo de malestar.
Por tanto, aunque todo esto
suene muy bonito,
cuando se produzca
un fallo de sistema,
lo primero que haré;
antes de empezar a quejarme,
antes de empezar a exigir a otros
que encuentren soluciones, antes
de empezar a maldecir mi mala suerte;
será preguntarme:
¿qué puedo hacer yo?
¿Qué puedo aportar a la solución?
¿Cómo puedo ayudar?
¿Cómo puedo sumar?
Lo primero que haré,
será preguntarme:
¿Y yo?
¿Qué puedo hacer?
Porque a lo mejor resulta que
puedo hacer mucho más
de lo que pensaba.
Eso es todo.
Muchas gracias por vuestra atención.